depuis cinq ans le feu a détruit plus de
3 millions d'hectares de forêt en
colombie britannique pour se protéger de
ces incendies quatre communautés du sud
est de la province ont adopté une
approche inusité elles ont enrôlé des
alliés colossaux à quatre pattes
[Musique]
les coups donnés au sud est de la
colombie britannique
au coeur de cette vallée qui sépare la
chaîne des monts plus heure des
rocheuses la petite ville de cranbrook
à l'entrée de la ville quelques
centaines de bovins pote allègrement
une scène pastorale qu'il n'ait rien
d'exceptionnel à première vue mais les
apparences sont trompeuses car si
beauvais sont ici en mission
protéger la ville de creil broc et
cévennes et l'habitat des feux de forêt
ont fait partie de cette communauté
alors on est bien content de pouvoir lui
rendre service
joli thibault est éleveur de bovins dans
les coûts tenait sur le ranch fondé par
son père dans les années 60
c'est 300 bêtes passent leur été à
parcourir les versants des montagnes
pour se nourrir
normalement répartir et les troupeaux
sur 16 bits hectares cette culture de ce
rythme là il est bête pourrait être sur
les plateaux où l'herbe est abondante
[Musique]
mais depuis 2020 ces vaches sont
confinés en juillet un secteur de 200
hectares aux abords de la ville de
cranbrook
[Musique]
on se sert du parcage intensif comme
outil on espère que le bétail brutal à
môtiers delerm quitte ici
[Musique]
comme bon nombre de villes et villages
de l'intérieur de la colombie
britannique
cranbrook est entourée de forêts
plusieurs propriétés situées en
périphérie de la ville sont entourés de
conifères
n'est pas la forêt qui manque autour de
nous changeons la rade est agronome au
ministère provincial des forêts et des
ressources naturelles
[Musique]
elles sont collés à la forêt
ce que craint cranbrook c ceux ci
l'histoire débute en 2003 la vallée de
l'okanagan est aux prises avec des feux
de forêt sans précédent
un brasier de 25 mille hectares pénètre
la zone forestière en bordure de la
ville de kelowna
le bilan est lourd trente trois mille
personnes évacuées 230 maisons détruites
200 millions $ de dommages
le sinistre mène à une foule de
recommandation
parmi les plus importantes la création
de zones de protection des boisés autour
des communautés
[Musique]
akron bourque on abat la quasi-totalité
des arbres ceinturant la ville à
commencer par le sud d'où viennent les
vents dominants
on sait plus sur tous les arbres morts
ou mourants victimes des infestations de
dendroctone du pin
est l'un des courts de la terre du
projet
on en fait un peu plus chaque année et
ça nous coûte cher les moulins ne
veulent pas de ce bourg mais qu'importe
c'est notre priorité
le principe est simple en coupant les
arbres on retire le carburant qui
permettrait un feu de s'approcher de la
ville mais ce faisant on crée un nouveau
problème
chant norad nous fait visiter un secteur
des voisines il y a trois ans
dès qu'on laisse la lumière pénétrer
dans le sous bois on stimule la
croissance on le voit ici s'est remplie
d'herbe on a remplacé un risque d'
incendies par un autre
on l'a vu dans les feux de broussailles
et en californie il se propage
rapidement et peuvent avoir de graves
conséquences
les feux de forêt de 2017 et 2018
jettent de la lumière sur ce problème
en deux ans 3500 feu détruisent deux
millions et demi d'hectares de forêt
soit l'équivalent de 3 % de la
superficie totale de la province
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
sont évacuées
les autorités s'inquiètent entre autres
que l'herbe sèche dans les zones
déboisées ne permette aux feux de
pénétrer les villes
mike woodson et le court donateurs de la
prévention contre les feux de forêt à
l'association des éleveurs de bovins de
la colombie britannique
il constate en 2018 que plusieurs
éleveurs de bovins se servent déjà de
grands pâturages libre en bordure des
communautés ici on forçait ses bêtes à
rester deux ou trois semaines chaque été
dans les petits secteurs des boisés une
vache adulte mange plus de 70 kilos
d'herbe par jour soit environ 10% de son
poids
en broutant les vaches agissent comme
des tondeuses l'herbe reste content mais
reste aussi verte plus longtemps ce qui
réduit les risques que naissant dits de
grande ampleur se déclare
l'association des éleveurs de bétail
obtient de la province le financement
nécessaire pour mettre en place un
projet pilote sur trois ans
emballé par l'initiative shona lowe rade
décide de s'investir dans le projet
reste maintenant à trouver des éleveurs
jordi thibault n'hésite pas à enrouler
ses vaches
ma première réaction est de rire parce
qu'évidemment les vaches mangent de
l'herbe alors on avait tout l'équipement
qu'il fallait
mais la tâche est exigeante il doit
d'abord monté plus de deux kilomètres de
clôtures électriques autour du secteur
ciblé de 200 hectares
[Musique]
construit deux cultures et en faire une
inspection tous les jours c'est beaucoup
de travail et instance il a dit on a
bien peu de temps libre
pour ce travail harassant il reçoit une
compensation de quelques milliers de
dollars
jody doit aussi garder un oeil attentif
sur la santé de son troupeau
l'usl plaine du pô mieux je me porte
certainement que les laisser aller sur
les versants des montagnes accéléraient
leur engraissement vu la plus grande
diversité de plantes qu'il ya là bas
c'est un facteur à considérer lorsque je
voudrais enlever les clôtures
mais comment quantifier la réduction
d'herbe dans ces secteurs
pour ce faire l'association des éleveurs
se tourner vers oman de meilleur
écologiste spécialisée dans la santé des
grands pâturages libre elle compare la
bio masse de matière organique dans les
parcelles brouter à celle des percées lé
témoin protégé des animaux
ces données nous permettent d'anticiper
la trajectoire et l'intensité du feu
ces données préliminaires montrent une
réduction de 35 % de la biomasse grâce
aux bovins mais amanda tente aussi de
répondre à une autre question
quel est l'impact du passage intensif
sur l'écosystème de la région
en train de perdre des espèces
fourragères au profit de plantes qui
sont moins utiles à la forme et à
l'ensemble de l'écosystème
2021 a été une autre allée dévastatrice
l'intérieur de la colombie britannique
en raison d'une vague de chaleur sans
précédent
16 sans feux ont ravagé près de 900
mille hectares de forêt les images du
petit village de l'été ne rasé par les
flammes ont fait le tour de la planète
lors de notre visé dans les coûts tenait
en juillet 2021 le ciel était à peine
visible en raison de la fumée intense
mais la ville de cranbrook n'a pas été
sérieusement menacé par un feu de forêt
depuis des décennies
ce qui fait dire à certains que son tour
arrivera plus tôt que tard
chaque année sans feu entraîne une
accumulation de matières organiques et
tous les arbres qui meurent ne font
qu'empirer la situation
selon terry baronne une série de feux
contrôlés pourrait aider à protéger la
ville à l'avenir mais la population
résiste ça crée beaucoup d'inquiétude
c'est feu à proximité des lieux habités
donc le pâturage intensif du bétail peut
représenter une excellente option il
faut sortir des sentiers battus
les promoteurs du projet pilote espère
que le pacage intensif deviendra à
l'avenir un outil permanent pour réduire
les dommages causés par les fuites
ferait
selon eux des dizaines de communautés en
colombie britannique pourrait en
bénéficier
il suffit de changer nos perceptions et
de voir le bêta et qui broutent
paisiblement au bord de la route des
différents
nous n'avons pas besoin d'aller chercher
très loin le bétail fait le travail pour
nous
[Musique]
je